[Music]
there's a growing controversy over
fortnight's use of viral hip-hop dances
which players can buy to customize their
avatars in the game many are saying a
move called the swipe it in fortnight is
clearly the Milly Rock a dance
introduced by rapper 2 million 2014 and
now seen in the halls of high schools
across the u.s. today
hip hop heavyweights like Chancellor
rapper are calling out the game for not
crediting or paying the artists or
responsible for popularizing the Milly
rock and other viral dances everything
I'm only crazy and people just you have
to sue fortnight
you have to sue you sue you should sue
you should sue use your suit but do
these artists have a case could
fortnight be held legally accountable
for making money off their dances beyond
the courtroom is it just epically wrong
and can you copyright a dance move this
question has become a topic of debate
with the rise of Fortnight preferred
person shooter game that has taken over
the gaming market since its launch in
September 2017 fortnight battle royale
has earned its owner epic games over 1
billion dollars in revenue that money
has come almost entirely from optional
in-game purchases fortnight players can
trade in real world money for a virtual
currency called V bucks they can spend v
bucks to unlock extras for their
fortnight avatars including special
missions cosmetic items and special
dance animations called emotes these
emotes are often based on real world
dances that were created by music
artists especially by artists in hip-hop
but genre in which many viral dance
trends actually begin
I don't like fortnight for that I don't
never play the game I don't think I
would ever play it but I just don't
think that they should have stole like
come on we go so hard for our talent or
whatever [ __ ] whatever we create epic
game did not reply to our requests for
comment but swipe it first appeared on
season 5 or fortnight and 2018 I was
doing the same moves seven years ago so
since then I was since then I just been
walking everywhere and never had a name
never had even a thought process about
making it something it was just like fun
in 2014 to milli dropped his breakout
hit milli rock before chorus I'm milli
rock on any block the song took off in
Vanilli rock went from a local dance to
a national craze with Beyonce merely
rocking at the Super Bowl in Rihanna
performing for dance on SNL fast forward
to 2017 when playboy cardi reignited
with Milly rock mania with his single
Magnolia the song had the infectious
hook in New York Amelie Rock Magnolia
went platinum with two Milly himself
serving up a remix of the song
Kendrick Lamar also gave the Milly Rock
a shout-out in his verse on new freezer
Milly rock is universe of people doing
the reggae don't I see people doing it
too hip-hop R&B do the slow rock to
Milly says for tonight isn't the only
game to use the Milly rock without
contacting him it actually was an NBA 2k
18 and I had people reach out to kind of
hand do that situation too to Millie's
fans weren't happy when what they
recognized as the Milly rock appeared in
season 5 for fortnight under a new name
for backlash to fortnight monetizing
what appears to be family lock was
overwhelming high-profile figures
weighed in as well chance for rapper
argued that for tonight's game makers
were profiting off the creations of
black artists without giving them fair
credit or compensation chance names of
Milly rock as an example he also cited a
shoot dance which is attributed to
Memphis rapper block boy JB and gets his
name from his 2017 single shoot block
boy brought the shoot into the
mainstream when he performed the dance
with Drake in their video to look alive
two months later for tonight out of a
shoot - its season four emotes calling
the dance for hype when it comes to
money Rob everyone knows I actually
created the dance black boy jb created
the shoot because he just it just came
out so yes of course compensate us this
is our craft
that you guys basically stole you stole
it for money so pay us our money to
Milly has been working with attorneys to
reach out to Epic Games and is hoping to
secure some kind of legal protection for
a middle rock if he or any other hip-hop
artists did decide to soup Epic Games
for the use of their dances whether it
be a legal basis for fair claims to find
the answer we spoke to intellectual
property lawyer basically in the eyes of
the law individual dance moves are seen
as the building blocks of choreographing
expression therefore allowing these
simpler elements of dance to be
copyrighted to stand in the way of
people's creative expression through
dance beyond copyright law many people
see this debate as a bigger ethical
issue one that raises important racial
cultural and economic concerns one study
found that almost 70% of Fortnight
players have spent money on optional
extras in the game of those players who
have made in-game purchases they had
spent an average of about $85
for tonight brought epic 318 million
dollars in May 2018 alone setting a
record for the highest monthly revenue
of any game on any platform in the
history of gaming as fortnight keeps
breaking its own records for revenue
other games may look the copy of an
in-game purchasing model going forward
making the controversy over monetize
dance animations
even more relevant in the future selling
the virtual versions of trendy dances
does more than just bring in revenue it
also lends cultural relevance to games
like fortnight helping generate interest
in the game even among non gamers some
people have voiced concerned that hip
hop's contribution to the gaming world
goes unrecognized they worry about
fortnight's from the appropriation of
dances will effectively erase for true
creators of these dance movements it
like it's hot oh my god
chance for rapper wants fortnight to
pair its emotes better based on hip-hop
dances with original songs and give the
artist a portion of the sales from those
in-game purchases instead of just
spilling these guys moves that they
create and naming it something else add
this song let us be able to to see where
that is coming from
you're gonna take someone's craft and
make billions of dollars of it why not
give them a great percentage now you
look at season 5 sales where they have
the milliwatt
the shoe the dab and ninety projected 2
billion themselves that says something i
says a lot
[Music]
you